how are you i'm really great how you
doing man good man
so first off let's just go this show
your track record on this show out of
the gate with season one like two
successful couples on something that
everybody thought was gonna be an
absolute disaster is pretty incredible
yeah i think we went into season one not
really knowing how it was going to play
itself out uh as well so um i don't say
it was a relief but it was it was nice
to see that you know we got not one but
two really you know
great lasting relationships you know
people who are happily married to this
day and i think that kind of validated
the show validated the experiment if you
will and and now entering season two
those
those singles who were part of season
two from chicago
have seen the success of season one they
know it works and so yeah you're not
convincing them that hey you gotta you
know you gotta put yourself out there
they already know they come in knowing
hey this is
let's trust this process it works and
and they really went for it which is uh
which is awesome
how long into season two before you were
surprised
that's something you saw i mean
i think that the real telling moment you
get surprised in the pods at least for
me because as
for us we're observing everything
happening and you're always
surprised at the connections that people
kind of make i didn't see that one
coming you know what i mean but that's
kind of the beauty of it too is that
that when you shed all the physical kind
of superficial judgmental things that
that plague people in the in the kind of
modern dating world you take all that
away
it's impossible to know who's going to
connect with who and for for what
reasons but that's what makes it
fascinating and that's what makes it
real is that you're you're building a
foundation with somebody based on who
they truly are and but for us on the
outside
it's hard to understand sometimes why
people end up together but that's that's
the beauty of it
uh much like love is blind and also too
hot to handle
in the first seasons nobody has any idea
what they're getting themselves into but
everybody else after that who maybe even
seen the show regardless of how well you
try and hide what they're being in in
involved in
you run the risk of getting people who
are there because they realize this may
just simply lead to more instagram
followers yeah
yeah that's i mean that's a real that's
a real thing and i mean for the for the
positives of having a successful season
one which i just talked about people
knowing that the process works and
trusting that process
there's no way to say you can't have
somebody who just wants to be on on tv
of course but i think for the most part
this is a this is an experience that you
don't just do because you you know i
mean like it's it's grueling and it's
it's emotionally taxing and it takes a
lot of emotional investment um and so i
trust that that these people um they're
there for the right reasons because
they've been in the modern day world and
it's not what they are looking for they
haven't found the connection
to someone that they're looking for um
and they think that they can find it
here and and i think you see that play
out in season two i mean it's it's uh
it's it's if you like season one season
two it's kind of like big or bad or
better than than season one yeah it's
it's it's it's wild um but yeah i mean
look let's be honest it's tv so there's
there's always potentially an element of
that um but our casting department does
a great job in finding people who are
truly just you know they're just fed up
with what they've been dealing with and
this is an opportunity to approach love
and finding love um from a very
different perspective than they're used
to
what are your thoughts on on two things
here one just the absolute joy of being
you know a couple in show business
getting to do something together with
you and vanessa but also when you guys
first got together were you sort of
doing a kind of long distance version of
this where you had to get to know each
other without being face to face
yeah yeah i mean we we started dating in
uh in 2006 and so you know back in those
days she was working in new york i was i
was living and working in la um and so
it was a lot of i mean while we didn't
know each other and we knew each other
or so we had met you know were friends
for years before that um it was a lot of
long
telephone conversations you know where
your ears like hurting at the end of it
and like you're asking all those
questions and getting to know someone
about you know from the inside out and
it's it was kind of as close to this i
think as you could get without being in
the pods we really spent a lot of time
just on the phone kind of the
old-fashioned way which is what drew us
to this to this project and what made it
you know resonate with us is that hey we
feel like that was a great foundation
for our relationship um which thankfully
we're you know 16 years into or what
have you but um
it really does work i think and and yes
physical becomes a part of it
introducing people's families and
friends becomes a part of it living
together becomes a part of it but
these couples really their foundation
for their relationship is this emotional
connection that they force in the pods
and that's uh you know that's that's the
exciting part and before i let you go
quickly you just answer you or or your
wife i'm sure that while you were
watching people in the pods you guys
have a better sense of who's going to
wind up hooking up out of all the people
you've obs who has a better record of
picking the couples you or vanessa i
think we both stink we i mean we you
think you know but then you're always
constantly you're surprised by what
happens um
yeah
i'll give the edge to her because she's
she's she's more intuitive than i am and
she's got a better radar so i'll give
the edge to her but it is that's what
makes the show so fascinating is that
you just simply don't know um it's uh
it's it's it's entertaining for us and
it's fascinating for us to watch it play
out as i think it is for for the public
watching uh nick the show's great uh you
guys are great on it i appreciate your
time thank you so much thank you have a
good one take it easy